The main motivation of Chord is scalable location
of data in a large distributed system. So
a publisher might want to publish the location
of a particular piece of data, such as an
MP4 with a particular name, such as Annie Hall. It needs to figure out where to
publish this data in a place that the
client can find it. So that when the client
performs a look up for Annie Hall, it's directed to
the right location that is hosting the data. The key problem
that we need to solve here is look up and
you can see that the function that needs to be provided
is just a simple hash table, but the thing that
makes this problem interesting is that the hash table isn't located
in one place but that it's distributed across the network. So
what we're trying to build is what's called a distributed hash
table or a DHT. The way that we're going to
build this is using a mechanism called consistent hashing.